las compañías de tecnológicas sus dueñas
de las redes sociales más influyentes
del mundo están en crisis meta de Mark
Zuckerberg que despedirá a 11.000
trabajadores el 13% de su plantilla en
su primer recorte masivo n 18 años de
existencia el nuevo dueño de Twitter
elon musk recordará a la mitad del
talento humano de la redes del Pájaro
Microsoft también ha hecho recortes Qué
es lo que está pasando con los
anunciantes de los que dependen en gran
parte los ingresos de estas compañías lo
vamos a analizar con Samir Estefan en
decidió detec etcétera y consultorio de
transformaciones digital Además está en
el estudio de France 24 Daniela Blandón
con todos los detalles para que podamos
llevar a cabo esta entrevista a Daniela
vamos a comenzar Entonces izamir el
zucker atribuyó los despidos a la
ralentización de la economía la mayor
competencia y también a la disminuciones
de los ingresos de publicidad porque
está en crisis la publicidad
yo creo que lo que estamos viendo Es un
coletazo de de algo que todo el mundo
esperaba que siguiera y que terminó
terminó pasando y es que después del
covid nos íbamos a quedar mucho más en
el mundo digital y menos en el mundo
físico y el mismo Soccer lo dice él Dice
pensamos que el tema iba a seguir
creciendo que íbamos a seguir
manteniendo este este ritmo de
crecimiento al que venía la compañía un
ritmo acelerado pero no fue así Esa es
la razón por la que hoy está echando un
paso para atrás
también quería preguntarles esto no
solamente concierne a meta no solamente
a Twitter sino a otras empresas Cuáles
son esas empresas que se están viendo
ahora afectadas Y qué pudo haber pasado
en en en no sé en los directivos de
estas compañías que no vieron venir
semejante crisis a la que nos íbamos a
ver a bocados después de la pandemia en
donde un Boom de de tecnológicas
Daniela yo creo que es que se nos pegan
como tres factores macroeconómicos en
medio de una situación que la gente no
estaba esperando el primero Es todo el
mundo sabía que después del covid iba a
ver digamos un poquito de ralentización
pero se nos viene encima de eso una de
las digamos crisis inflacionarias más
grandes que hemos visto en los últimos
años por lo menos a nivel global y
encima de eso vemos la guerra en Ucrania
y encima de eso vemos un ataque gigante
de tiktok sobre todas estas empresas de
redes sociales norteamericanas Entonces
al final lo que estamos viendo y creo
que son dos mundos muy diferentes el de
meta es un mundo en el cual la compañía
está diciendo Oiga voy a tener que
despedir 11.000 personas que de todas
maneras no lo pone ni siquiera el nivel
de empleados que tenían el mediados de
2021 no o sea todavía está por encima de
lo que tenía en el 2021 Pero por otro
lado subimos un Twitter que pues tiene
un dueño nuevo y que Sencillamente lo
que está haciendo es entrar a controlar
los gastos para ver cómo hace para
sobrevivir la compañía y tratar de
volver rentable una inversión que como
hemos hablado con ustedes en el pasado
Pues fue un poco exce
claro y hablemos un poco más de esto
porque ahí los que envió un correo a sus
empleados anunciándoles Que vendrían
tiempos difíciles y aquí yo le quiero
preguntar si esos tiempos difíciles
tienen relación precisamente con que sea
y los que quien está ahora al frente de
Twitter y esto genera algo de
incertidumbre para los anunciantes
Sí yo creo que pues en parte yo creo que
lo que ha pasado es que esta última
semana y media ha sido una semana como
de tiro y afloje de lanzar muchas
propuestas de eliminarlas muy rápido y
creo que los anunciantes están todavía
un poco asustados de que puede llegar a
pasar con esa promesa del de la
plataforma digital en donde todos
podamos hablar libremente independiente
de nuestros puntos de vista los
anunciantes creo que están un poco
asustados pero lo otro también Es que
creo que pues estamos acostumbrados a
ver una compañía de carácter público que
tiene unas expectativas trimestres
trimestre y lo que estamos viendo Es
ahora una compañía de carácter privado
en el que el dueño dice Oiga tenemos que
amarrarnos el cinturón vamos a bajar los
gastos de tal manera que podamos volver
a ser digamos un negocio viable eh
incluso habló de que la posibilidad de
declarar la compañía en quiebra el
próximo año
también quiero que profundicemos sobre
el tema de Twitter porque hay una crisis
de anunciantes específicamente en
Twitter y es porque él es una especie de
castigo
ahí por todos los anuncios que ha hecho
por la el nerviosismo que ha causado con
con anuncios que un día dice una cosa al
otro día dice otra Cómo podemos analizar
esta situación en Twitter
específicamente
Sí yo no creo que sea un tema de castigo
lo que creo Es que es un tema de
incertidumbre los anunciantes están muy
cautelosos quieren entender qué va a
pasar quién entender cómo va a ser
digamos esta apertura a todas las voces
una de las grandes preocupaciones Es que
la plataforma vuelva y se llene como lo
vimos hace un par de años de mensajes de
odio sobre todo de la ultraderecha
norteamericana que hoy por hoy digamos
está en otras plataformas y creo de una
u otra manera que los anunciantes pues
además están esperando
sesión por lo menos en lo que es el
primer semestre del próximo año entonces
están diciendo vamos a pausar vamos a
seguir pautando algo en otras redes
sociales pero por ahora Aquí vamos a
poner la pausa y pues claramente una
compañía que depende en un 80 85 87% de
sus ingresos en la Pauta pues está
viendo el tema complicado saber qué tan
consolidada está la visión del metaverso
de Mark Zuckerberg la crisis se
relaciona con esta apuesta en una
inversión por conquistar ese metaverso
que no ha visto retribución es decir
ahora con esta crisis se tiene que dar
marcha atrás hace Pero puede que a
mediano o a largo plazo Mark Zuckerberg
se convierta como ha esperado en este
gran dominante del mundo digital
lo que pasa es que yo creo que nosotros
desde afuera estamos viendo el tema del
metaverso mañana cuando él mismo ha
dicho que esto no lo vamos a ver antes
de cinco yo creería en realidad unos 10
años Sí él no tiene como echar paso
atrás Sencillamente porque él no puede
que él no puede permitir que a la
compañía le pase lo que le pasó con la
revolución del dispositivo móvil en
donde a pesar de ser mucho más grande
que todos los demás necesita pasar por
los por los dispositivos de Apple o de
Google para poder llegar a sus usuarios
entonces él se está preparando para esa
Nueva Ola de innovación que no va a
llegar antes de cinco años y que como él
dijo desde el comienzo va a costar mucha
plata pero claramente un un gasto como
el que estamos viendo unas pérdidas
operativas de más de 3000 millones cada
trimestre pues no aguantan ninguna
compañía y por eso ha tenido que entrar
a recortar en otros segmentos en donde
está viendo que no va a haber
crecimiento muy rápidamente Samir ya
para cerrar si no es con la publicidad
De qué otra manera podrían seguir
evolucionando las redes sociales
donde están apuntando a tratar de ver y
de ser lo que pasa con WeChat en China
que haya transacciones que haya pagos
que haya que sirvan de alguna manera
como intermediario financiero que haya
servicios en donde la gente termina
pagando por ellos como ya también lo
anunció el mismo ir en mosca entonces
creo que vamos a ver una diversificación
de los ingresos Más allá de la
publicidad para servicios de valor
agregado por los que la gente realmente
quiera pagar